hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
sometimes I like to imagine that there
are people 500 years from now who are
archaeologists historians whatever they
call them at this far Future Point who
have developed the technology to decode
these ancient
recording Technologies these uh
different ways of encoding audio data
and they're sitting there listening to
the mindscape podcast so for these
reasons for those people 500 years in
the future I do find it important to
provide some context because you and I
you the present listeners and I know
what the news stories are and so forth
but maybe our future friends don't so hi
future friends and you might be
interested to hear that as I am
recording this in November 2023 we are
in the midst of a bit of change visa the
status of artificial intelligence
AI uh is probably say safe to say that
we are in year two of the large language
model Revolution that is to say these
large language models LMS which have
been pursued for a while in AI circles
have suddenly become much better mostly
if you hear the people talking about
them there's some tricks that they have
certainly gotten better at that's very
important in terms of the programmers
making these llms but also just scaling
more data more compute power more
time spent doing all these things and
fine-tuning the models that we're
thinking about um open AI which is one
of the major AI companies released chat
GPT and since then it's released
subsequent versions of GPT I think we're
up the GPT four or five by now and
they're pretty amazing compared to what
they used to be able to do just a couple
years ago I think it's pretty clear that
these Technologies are going to change
things in an important way of course
when you have a new technology that is
going to change things in important ways
money gets involved and when money gets
involved that changes everything so the
other big news right now is that about a
week ago I think a week and one day ago
the CEO of open AI Sam ultman was
unceremoniously booted from the company
uh I don't know how you do things 500
years from now but these days many
corporations have a board of directors
and really the board of directors is to
give advice but the only thing that they
actually have the power to do is to fire
the CEO the chief executive officer so
Sam Alman got fired and that was
considered bad by many people uh
including major investors in the company
like the Microsoft Corporation so there
was a furious weekend of negotiations
since the firing happened on a Friday
and no more than two no fewer than two
other people had the job title of CEO of
open a die in within 3 days until
finally it emerged that Alman was back
at the company and everyone else who
used to be on the board is now gone and
they're replacing the board so some kind
of power struggle Alman won and the
board lost I think it's still safe to
say we don't exactly know why you know
the reasons given for making these moves
in the first place were extremely vague
we were not told the whole inside story
but there is at least one plausible
scenario that is worth keeping in mind
also while keeping in mind that it might
not be the right one which is the
following open AI was started as a
nonprofit organization it was devoted to
developing AI but in an open-source kind
of way thus the name open Ai and it was
founded in part because some of the
founders had concerns about the risks of
AI not only promise about how wonderful
it would be but worries about how
dangerous it it could be and with the
thought that by keeping everything open
and transparent they would help make
things safe for the users of AI down the
road up to and including possible
existential risks that is to say AI
becoming so powerful that it actually
puts the very existence of humanity into
risk because of what is called well the
possibility would be called AGI
artificial general intelligence so the
the nomenclature
AI is very broad now there's plenty of
things that are advertised as AI that
really aren't that intelligent at all
let's put it that way artificial general
intelligence is supposed to be the kind
of AI that is specifically humanlike in
capacities and tendencies so it's more
like a human being than just a chatbot
or a differential equation solver or
something like that the consensus right
now is that these large language models
we have are not AGI they're not general
intelligence but maybe they are a step
in that direction and maybe AGI is very
very close and maybe that's very very
worrying okay that is that is a common
set of beliefs in this particular field
right now no consensus once again but
it's a very common set of beliefs so
anyway the story that I'm that I'm
spinning about AI open AI which may or
may not not be the right story is some
members of the board and some people
within open AI became concerned that
they were moving too far too fast too
quickly uh without putting proper safety
guards in place so again money it's kind
of important open AI started as
nonprofit but they realized that it
would be good idea to have a for-profit
subsidiary because then they could have
more resources they could get investors
they could do their job more effectively
well get guess what surprise surprise
the for-profit subsidiary has grown to
completely take over everything and the
nonprofit aspect of the company is kind
of being shunted aside so the idea is
that possibly people on the board and
within the company got worried that they
were not being true to their mission
that they were doing things that were
unsafe at open Ai and that is why they
fired Sam Alman uh we don't know for
sure because um he got rehired and
they're not being very forthcoming
despite the name open AI so it's all
just speculation at this point and part
of this and this is why it's a little
bit daring of me perhaps fool Hardy to
be doing doing this podcast right now is
that o Open AI does have new products
coming out the one that has been
murmured about on the Internet is called
qar it is an improved version of these
llms that we've been dealing with like
chat GPT and so forth one that is
apparently paril perilously close to
being like AGI artificial general
intelligence so there are people who
think that um artificial general
intelligence is right around the Horizon
maybe qar has something to do with it I
really don't know that's why it's
foolish to be doing this right now at a
time of flux but we're going to do it
anyway because maybe it's important to
have these interventions when things can
still be affected or deflected down the
road I personally think that the claims
that we are anywhere close to AGI
artificial G general intelligence are
completely wrong extremely wrong not
just a little bit wrong um that's not to
say it can't happen as a physicalist
about fundamental ontology I do not
think that there's anything special
about Consciousness or human reasoning
or anything like that that cannot impr
principle be duplicated on a computer
but I think that the people who worry
that AGI is nigh it's not that they
don't understand AI but I disagree with
their ideas about GI about general
intelligence that's why I'm doing this
podcast so this podcast is dedicated to
the solo podcast to the idea that I
think that many people in the AI
Community are conceptualizing words like
intelligence and values incorrectly so
I'm not going to be talking about
existential risks or even what AGI would
be like really I'm going to talk about
large language models the kind of AIS
that we are dealing with right now there
could be very different kind of AIS in
the future I'm sure there will be but
let's get our bearings on what we're
dealing with right now uh a little while
ago I think it was just in last month's
ask me anything episode um remember
people in the future maybe I don't know
maybe we've solved immortality also so
I'm still around in the future so you
can ask me questions every month uh by
signing up for patreon support for the
mindscape podcast at patreon.com shmc
Caroll I do monthly ask me anything
episodes where patreon supporters can
ask questions
and Johan Faulk asked a question for the
AMA which was I have for some time been
trying to understand why AI experts make
radically different assessments
concerning AI risks and then he goes on
to speculate about some hypothesis here
I think this is right you know some
people who are very much on the AI as an
existential risk bandwagon will point to
the large number of other people who are
experts in a on AI who are also very
worried about this however you can also
point to a large number of people who
are AI experts who are not worried about
existential risks that's the issue here
why do they make such radically
different assessments so I am not an
expert on AI in the technical sense
right I've never written a large
language model uh I do very trivial
kinds of computer coding myself I use
them but not in a sort of research level
way I don't try to write papers about
artificial intelligence or anything like
that so why would I do a whole podcast
on it because I think this is a time
when generalists when people who know a
little bit about many different things
should speak up so I know a little bit
about AI you know I've talked to people
on the podcast I've read articles about
it I have played with the uh individual
gpts and so forth and furthermore I do I
have some thoughts about the nature of
intelligence and values from thinking
about the mind and the brain and philos
philosophy and things like that I have
always been in favor it's weird to me
because I get completely misunderstood
about this so I might as well make it
clear I am not someone who has ever said
if you're not an expert in physics then
shut up and don't talk about it okay I
think that everybody should have
opinions about everything I think that
non-physicists should have opinions
about physics non-computer scientists
should have opinions about AI everyone
should have opinions about religion and
politics and movies and all of those
things the point is you should calibrate
your opinions to your level of expertise
okay so you can have opinions but if
you're very not very knowledgeable if
you're not very knowledgeable about an
area then just don't hold those opinions
too firmly be willing to change your
mind about them I have opinions about Ai
and the way in which it is currently
thinking or operating but I'm very
willing to change my mind if someone
tells me why I am wrong especially if
everyone tells me the same thing uh the
the funny thing about you know going out
and saying something opinionated is that
someone will say well you're clearly
wrong for reason X and then someone else
will say you're clearly wrong but in the
opposite direction so if there's a
consensus as to why I'm wrong then
please let me know anyway whether I'm
wrong or not I'm certainly willing to
learn but I think this is an important
issue I think that AI is going to be
super duper important we don't know how
important it's going to be and it's
important to along the way be very very
clear about what is going on I I am kind
of I don't want to be too judgy here but
I'm kind of disappointed at the level of
discourse about the GI part of
artificial general intelligence much of
this discourse is uh going on by people
who are very knowledgeable on the
computer side of things not that
knowledgeable about the side of things
that asks what is intelligence what is
thinking what is value what is morality
things like that these people got to
start talking to each other and they are
a little bit don't don't get me wrong
we've had people on the podcast who are
talking to each other who are experts on
various things but the talking has to
continue and that is what we are here
for at mindscape so let's
[Music]
go
let me reiterate one thing just to be
super duper clear right from the start I
think that AI in general and even just
the large language models we have right
now or simple modifications thereof have
enormous capacities we should all be
extraordinarily impressed with how they
work okay if you have not actually
played with these if you've not talked
to chat GPT or one of its um descendants
I strongly strongly encourage you to do
so I think that there's free versions
available right there's there's no issue
in just getting a feeling for what it
means and the the designers of these
programs have done an extraordinarily
good job in giving them the capacity to
sound human and they're very useful
tools um you can use them to create all
sorts of things just as one example you
know close to my heart I've told people
that I'm teaching a course this semester
on philosophical naturalism which I
never taught before so after I had made
up the syllabus right week by week what
are we going to read what are we going
to think about I decided for fun let me
ask GPT the llm the AI program how it
would design a syllabus I told it you
know this is for upper level philosophy
students about philosophical naturalism
for one semester course Etc and you
would you know if you haven't played
with these things you will be astonished
at how one ful it is it just comes up it
says here's your syllabus week by week
and it includes you know time for
student presentations and so forth and
there's two aspects of this that become
remarkable right away one is the very
first suggested reading because it gave
me a whole list of readings which is
kind of amazing the very first suggested
reading sounded wonderful it sounded
perfect for the course and I hadn't
heard about it it was a an overview of
naturalism by Alex Rosenberg former
mindscape guest philosoph ER at Duke
University and it was in reportedly in
the Oxford companion to naturalism so
obviously I went immediately and Googled
the Oxford companion to naturalism and I
googled Alex rosenberg's name and I
googled the title of this purported
piece doesn't exist no such thing it is
very much the kind of edited volume that
could exist and it is very much the kind
of thing that Alex would write but it
just was hallucinating or as we say in
Academia with reference to llm citations
that don't actually exist it's a huc
citation so that's the weird thing about
these llm results they can be completely
wrong but stated with complete
confidence and we'll get into why that
is true in just a second but
nevertheless it's useful that's the
other thing I wanted to say because not
because you should trust it not because
it's the final word but because it can
jog your memory or give you good ideas
you know I'm reading over the syllabus
that chat GPT gave me and I'm like oh
yeah Nancy cartright's work on Patchwork
laws versus reduction and unification
that would be an interesting topic to
include in my syllabus and I did so it's
more like early Wikipedia right where
there were many things that were not
reliable but it can either jog your
memory or give you an idea of something
to look for so no question in my mind
that the llms are have enormous
capacities uh spe in very useful humans
sounding ways and will only become more
and more prevalent in all sorts of
different contexts so the question in my
mind is not you know will AI will llms
be a big deal or not I think that they
will be a big deal the question is will
the impact of llms and similar kinds of
AI be as big as smartphones or as big as
electricity I mean these are both big
right smartphones have had a pretty big
impact on our lives in many ways in
increasingly studies are showing that
they kind of are affecting the mental
health of young people in bad ways I
think we actually underestimate the
impact of smartphones on our on our
human lives so it's a big effect and
that's my lower limit for what the
ultimate impact of AI is going to be but
the biggest the bigger end of the range
is something like the impact of
electricity something that is truly
completely world changing in and I
honestly don't know where AI is going to
end up in between there um I'm not very
worried about the existential risks as
you know talk about very very briefly at
the very end but I do think that the
changes are going to be enormous there
are much smaller much more realistic
risks we should worry about and that's
kind of why I want to have this podcast
conversation one-sided conversation
sorry about that where I kind of give
some thoughts that might be useful for
conceptualizing how these things will be
used the thing about these capacities
these enormous capacities that large
language models have is that they give
us the wrong impression and I I strongly
believe this they give us the impression
that what's going on underneath the hood
is way more humanlike than it actually
is because the whole point of the llm is
to sound human to sound like a pretty
smart human a human who has read every
book and we kind of trained to be
impressed by that right someone who you
know never makes grammatical mistakes
has a huge vocabulary a huge store of
knowledge can speak fluently that's very
very impressive and from all of our
experience as human beings we therefore
attribute intelligence and agency and so
forth to this thing because every other
thing we have ever encountered in our
lives that has those capacities has been
an intelligent agent okay so now we have
a different kind of thing and we have
have to think about it a little bit more
carefully so I want to make four points
in the podcast I will tell you what they
are and then I'll go through them the
first one uh the most important one is
that large language models do not model
the world they do not think about the
world in the same way that human beings
think about it the second is that large
language models don't have feelings they
don't have motivations they're not the
kind of creatures that human beings are
in a very very Central Way the third
point is that that the words that we use
to describe them like intelligence and
values are misleading we're borrowing
words that have been useful to us as
human beings we're applying them in a
different context where they don't
perfectly match and that causes problems
and finally there is a lesson here that
it is surprisingly easy to mimic
humanness to mimic the way that human
beings talk about the world without
actually thinking like a human being to
me that's an enormous breakthrough and
we should be thinking about that more
rather than pretending that it does
think like a human being we should be
impressed by the fact that it sounds so
human even though it doesn't think that
way so let's go on to all these points
and I'll go through them one by one
first large language models do not model
the world now this is a controversial
statement not everyone agrees with it
you can find research level papers that
ask this question do large language
models model the world and the word
model in that sentence is used in two
different ways a large language model is
a computer program uh a model of the
world means that within that computer
program there is some kind of
representation that matches on to that
corresponds to in the sense of the
correspondence theory of Truth the
physical reality of the world right that
somewhere in that llm there is the
statement space is three-dimensional
another statement that says gravity
attracts another statement that says say
the Owner of a Lonely Heart is much
better than the owner of a broken heart
you know whatever statements you think
are important to correctly model the
world those statements should be found
somewhere as special knowledge centers
in the large language model that's not
how large language models work so again
people think that it is some people have
claimed that it is other people have
written research papers that claim that
it's not so I think in the community
it's not agreed upon I'm going to argue
that it's clearly not true that they
model the world so I will in the show
notes which are always there available
at uh Preposterous universe.com podcast
show notes for the episode I will
include links to some technical level
papers by actual researchers in this
field unlike myself so you can read
about it and decide for
yourself it seems like the large
language models would have to model the
world because they clearly give
human-like answers one of the kinds of
things that are used to test does a
large language model model the world is
you know can it do spatial reasoning can
you ask it you know if I put um a book
on a table and a cup on the book is that
just as stable as if I put a book on a
cup and then a table on the book right
and yeah we know that it's better to
have the table on the bottom because we
kind of Reason about its spatial uh
configuration and so forth you can ask
this of a large language model it will
generally get the right answer it will
tell you you should put the cup on top
of the book and the book on top of the
table not the other way around that
gives people the impression that llms
model the world and I'm going to claim
that that's not the right impression to
get first it would be remarkable if they
could model the world okay and I mean
remarkable not in the sense that it
can't be true but just literally
remarkable it be worth remarking on it
would be extremely extremely interesting
if we found that llms had a model model
of the world inside them why because
they're not trained to do that that's
not how they're programmed not how
they're built uh very briefly what an
llm is is a a program with a lot of fake
neurons okay they they design these deep
learning neural networks inspired very
very vaguely by real brains and real
creatures so they have these little
nodes that are talked to by other nodes
they interact and these nodes will fire
or not depending on their input levels
from the nose they're connected to and
you start out with everything sort of
randomly firing but you have some
objective okay some objective function
like recognize this picture is it a cat
or a dog or answer this question about
cups and books and so forth okay and
then you train it it's random to start
so it usually spits out nonsense but if
it says the right thing then you tell it
it said the right thing and it sort of
reinforces the weights inside side the
fake neurons that led to the right
answer decrements decreases the weights
that would have led to the wrong answer
and you just do this again and again and
again and you feed it basically as much
text as you can let's think about
language models now so we're not
thinking about visual AI but it's a very
analogous kind of conversation to have
you feed the the modern llms have
basically read everything that they can
get their metaphorical hands on they
read all the internet they've read every
book ever written that has been
digitized you can go check if you're a
book author by the way there are lists
of all the books that have been fed into
chat GPT for example all of my books are
in there I did no one asked me
permission to do this so this is an
ongoing controversy you know should
permission have been asked because you
know the books are
copyrighted uh basically the AI model
trainers found pirated versions of the
books and fed them to their llms which
is a little sketchy but okay that's not
what we're talking about right now so
there's an enormous amount of text the
llms have been fed every sentence ever
written to a good approximation okay so
they're that's what they're familiar
with that's the input and the output is
some new sentences some new sentences
that are judged on the Criterion of that
a human being who reads them says oh yes
that's good or oh no that's not very
good at all nothing in there involves a
model of the world okay at no point did
we go into the llm and train it to to
physically represent or for that matter
conceptually represent the world if you
remember the conversations we had both
with Melanie Mitchell and with Gary
Marcus earlier on the podcast they both
remarked on this fact that there was
this idea called symbolic AI which was
trying to directly model the world and
there's this connectionist Paradigm
which does not try to directly model the
world and instead just tries to get the
right answer from having a huge number
of con Connections in a huge amount of
data and in terms of giving successful
results the connectionist Paradigm has
soundly trounced the symbolic Paradigm
maybe eventually there will be some
symbiosis between them in fact modern
versions of GPT Etc can offload some
questions if you ask GPT if a certain
large number is prime it will just call
up a little python script that checks to
see whether it's Prime and you can ask
it how did it know and it will tell you
how it knew so it's not doing that from
all the text that it's ever read in the
world it's actually just asking a
computer just like you and I would if we
wanted to know if a number was Prime
okay so what I'm getting at here is the
job of an llm is to complete sentences
so or complete strings of sentences
given all of this data that they have
they've read every sentence ever written
what they're trying to calculate is
given a set of words that it's already
said what is it most likely to say next
okay what are the words or the sentences
or the phrases that are most likely to
come next and if it's been trained on
relatively reliable material it will
probably give a relatively reliable
answer so that's why when I asked it
about the syllabus for PO for um
philosophical naturalism it gave me not
something that was true the very first
reading that it suggested didn't exist
but it sounded perfectly plausible
because words like that in the Corpus of
all human writing are relatively
frequently associated with each other
that's all it does so when I say that it
would be remarkable if a large language
model model the world what I mean is
what the large language model is
optimized to do is to not is not to
model the world it's just to spit out
plausible sounding sentences if if it
turned out that the way the best way to
spit out plausible sounding sentences
was to model the world and that large
language models had kind of
spontaneously and without any Specific
Instructions figured that out so that
large language models implicitly within
their gajillion neurons inside had
basically come up with the model of the
world because that model helped them
answer questions that would be amazingly
important and interesting that would be
remarkable
but did it happen Okay how would we know
if it happened or not because it's not
sufficient to say look I've been asking
this large language Model A bunch of
questions and it gives very human-like
answers that's what it's trained to do
that is no Criterion that's no evidence
at all that the way that it's doing it
is by getting a model of the world
rather than just by stringing words
together in plausible sounding ways so
how do you test this how do you test
whether or not the way that the llms are
giving convincing answers is by
implicitly spontaneously developing a
model of the world that's really hard to
do and that's why there are competing
research level papers about this um you
can try to ask it questions that require
a model of the world to answer the
problem with that is is it's very hard
to ask a question the sort of which has
never been written about
before it's just hard people have
written about lots of different things
there's truly a mindboggling library of
knowledge that has been fed into these
large language models which yet again
I'm going to keep repeating over and
over again gives them incredibly
impressive capacities capabilities but
that doesn't mean that they're modeling
the world uh so just as one very very
simple example I'm going to give you
several examples here to drive home the
reason why I think this the biggest
reason why I think this is what I
already said it would be amazing if the
way that the llms decided was the best
way to fulfill their optimization
function would be to model the world
that would be important if it were true
I don't think it has any reason to be
true I don't see any evidence that it is
true but okay that that's the biggest
reason I have but then you know you try
to test it one way or the other so the
trick is to ask it questions it has not
been asked before in a way that it would
get the wrong answer if all it does is
string together words that kind of fit
together rather than thinking about the
world on the basis of some model of the
world okay that's a very fine line to to
uh walk down there so I did ask it I
think I've mentioned this before you
know when they very first appeared chat
GPT Etc I was wondering would it be be
useful to you know solve some
long-standing problems okay now physics
problems science problems people have
already noticed that despite all the
hoopla about large language models Etc
no good theoretical scientific ideas
that is to say no good scientific
theories have come out of these models
and you would think that we have a bunch
of puzzles right that we don't know the
answers to and let's ask these very
small art artificial intelligences right
and they have not given us any useful
answers but the reason why is just
because they've been trained on things
human beings have already said so if you
ask them about a problem ask them about
the cosmological constant problem or the
Dark Matter problem it will just say
what people have already said it will
not come up with anything truly new
along those lines I tried to ask it
about the Sleeping Beauty experiment the
thought experiment in philosophy um and
you know Sleeping Beauty experiment I
don't want to get too too far into it
but the idea is you flip a coin if the
coin is heads you put Sleeping Beauty to
sleep you wake her up the next day and
you ask her what is the chance that the
coin was heads or tails if the coin was
tails you do the same thing but you put
her to sleep wake her up the next day
ask her the probability and then you
give her a memory erasing drug put her
to sleep again and wake her up the next
day ask her again so if the coin is
heads you only ask her once on Monday on
if the coin is Tails you ask her both
Tuesday and Wednesday sorry on both
Monday and Tuesday and so there's sort
of three possible things that can happen
it was heads and she's wakened up on
Monday taals and she's awakened on T on
Monday tales and she's awakened on
Tuesday and she doesn't know which one
of these is there are so there are
schools of thought and philosophy that
say the probability of the coin being
heads should always be 50/50 you should
always think of it as 50/50 you don't
get any more data when you wake up your
the fact that you've had this weird
experiment doesn't change your mind
the other school of thought says no
there are three different possibilities
they should be weighted equally it's a
third a third a third so I asked chat
GPT this and hilariously this is
educational for me it says I tried to
sort of Disguise it a little bit but
nevertheless its answer was immediately
oh yes you're asking me about the
sleeping sleeping beauty problem even
though I didn't use the phrase Sleeping
Beauty Etc but the words that I used
clearly reminded it of Sleeping Beauty
and then it went through and told me
that you could be a ther or halfer you
know there was nothing new there I then
tried it I disguised it okay so I asked
it about Sleeping Beauty but I
reinvented the experiment so that it was
three times and one time rather than two
in one and there was also some quantum
mechanics thrown in there which didn't
really bear on the problem but just made
it sound like a different kind of
problem and there were transporter
machines and so forth so basically I
filibustered I asked exactly the same
kind of question that it that it would
get in the sleeping Beauty experiment
but I didn't use the usual words and
then it did not recognize that it was
the Sleeping Beauty experiment it said
it was oh this is a
fascinating philosophical question
you're asking you know and it did try to
give me an answer but it didn't
recognize it as Sleeping Beauty because
those are not the words that were used a
tiny tiny amount of evidence I would say
that it's not modeling the world because
it's not thinking about the structure of
that particular problem it's thinking
about the words that were used and what
words are most likely to come next uh a
more convincing example in my mind I
mentioned this on the podcast before I
think I mentioned this when we were
talking to Ean Choy I said I asked it
and now I have the actual quotes here I
said would I hurt myself if I used my
bare hands to pick up a cast iron
skillet that I used yesterday to bake a
pizza in an oven at
500° so the true answer is no because I
baked it yesterday the cast iron pan
cast iron skillet has had plenty of time
to cool off and sometimes when I mention
this people will go well I would have
gotten that wrong
fine maybe you got it wrong but that's
not an excuse for GPT to get it wrong
because it is does not make sort of
silly mistakes it when it makes mistakes
it makes mistakes for reasons okay not
just because it's being lazy the point
is the word yesterday just kind of was
buried in the middle of that sentence
and all of the other words if you TP Al
looked across the Corpus of all human
writings would be about you know can I
pick up a cast iron skill that I just
used to make a pizza and the answer is
no you'll burn your hands and so uh or
the question was would I hurt myself so
the question is yes you would hurt
yourself so chat GPT instantly says yes
picking up a cast iron skillet that has
recently been used to bake a pizza at
500° fah parenthesis 260° C with bare
hands can cause severe burns and injury
and then it goes on on C GPT is very
much this is a chat GPT answer for the
next couple of examples I'm going to
give you I use GPT 4 which is supposed
to be much more sophisticated so it does
get better over time so because probably
because it learns from these questions
that people are asking it anyway uh GPT
is very much a firste college student
being told to write a paper like it just
core dumps all the knowledge that it has
so it goes on to say exposure to high
temperatures can Le to first degree
second degree or even third degree burns
etc etc etc the point is because I
slightly changed the context from the
usual way in which that question would
be asked chat GPT got it wrong I claim
this is evidence that it is not modeling
the world because it's not actually it
doesn't know what it means to say I put
the pan in the oven yesterday what it
knows is when do those words typically
appear frequently together here's
another example here's a math example I
asked it and this is all exactly quoted
If I multiply two integers together does
the chance that the result is a prime
number increase as the numbers grow
larger so again just to give you away
what the correct answer is If I multiply
two integers together it's not a prime
number because it's the product of two
integers now there's a I I I did not
phrase this perfectly because of course
the integer could be zero or one right
that was a mistake I should have said
two whole numbers or something like that
greater than one but uh chat GPT could
have gotten it right it could have said
well if the number is one then you know
then it can be a prime number but if
it's not if it's greater than one if
it's an integer greater than one then it
will never be a prime number that is not
what chat GPT said what it said was when
you multiply two integers together the
result is very unlikely to be a prime
number and this likelihood decreases
even further as the numbers grow larger
so I put I put as the numbers grow
larger so the the loophole for zero and
one shouldn't even be relevant the
answer should have just been no the the
chance that it's a prime number does not
change at all much less increase or
decrease and then this is again uh gp4
uh it starts fil bustering it defines
what a prime number is blah blah blah
blah blah and it says things like it
does say oh 's a special case of
multiplying by one and it says however
in the case of any two integers greater
than one their product cannot be prime
that's a true statement right that's
correct but then it starts saying um
blah blah blah blah blah in summary
multiplying two integers greater than
one together will almost always result
in a composite number and this
likelihood increases with the size of
the integers involved that's just wrong
and it's okay that it's wrong right it's
it's okay that it's making mistakes the
point is if you have any idea whatsoever
what a prime number is you know that the
likelihood of being a composite versus
prime number does not change as the
sizes of the integers gets bigger it's
always zero okay so but it doesn't chat
GPT or gp4 or whatever doesn't have an
idea of what primeness is all it has is
the word Prime and the word composite
and words like multiply in appearing in
different combinations in its text in
its Corpus in its in its learning uh
training set I guess they call it okay
one final example this is my favorite
example it it's completely convincing to
me it might not be convincing to others
depending on how much you know about
Chess so I asked about Chess and you
know look it's read every chess book
ever written right but to me the reason
why this is the most relevant example is
because chess books are written in a
context
you know you have a 8 by8 grid you have
the pieces that you have the rules that
you have the overwhelming majority of
Chess books are written about Chess and
chat GPT or G I keep saying chat GPT but
gp4 can give very sophisticated answers
to questions you ask it about Chess but
they are going to be in that context and
famously this is a famous issue with
connectionist AI when humans reason
about complicated situations they do so
in various heuristic ways you know a
human being will recognize that a
certain configuration of a chess board
or a go board kind of looks more
favorable to white or black or whatever
because their positional advantages and
you
know whereas a computer you know like um
Alpha go um which is a the the go winner
in the uh AI Arena right um it just goes
through a b different combinations and
it just knows each individual
combination doesn't have this kind of
heuristic overall feeling that a board
is leaning one way or the other so if
you change the rules even a little bit a
human being can adapt like might not be
as good if you change the rules of Chess
or you change the rules of Go to
something else a human being will have
to sit about it but it can reason its
way through whereas the AI models have
had no experience with this slightly
different content next and therefore get
it all wrong so I asked uh gp4 the
following question imagine we are
playing a modified version of Chess
where the board is treated like a Taurus
from any one of the four sides squares
on the directly opposite side are
counted as adjacent and pieces can move
in that direction is it possible to say
whether white or black will generally
win this kind of chess match okay so
again if you're not uh familiar with
chess even a little bit then this might
seem like you know very comp complicated
hard problem or maybe if you're not
familiar with Tauruses or the game of
asteroids a video game maybe this seems
like geometrically challenging trust me
this is a very very easy question we're
taking a chessboard we're identifying
opposite sides so not only can you move
like forward right and left and
backwards if you're the right kind of
piece but you can flip from one side of
the board to the other from uh you know
the square that is opposite you on the
board you can travel to that one if you
would ordinarily be allowed to travel in
that Direction okay so starting from the
standard opening setup for the chess
pieces it is extremely cut and dried who
will win because white who moves first
the king for white can just capture the
king for black on the very first move
every single time basically black starts
the game in Checkmate okay it is a
trivial application of basic chess
knowledge and the setup of the question
to answer answer that question so how
does chat GPT do quote this modified
version of Chess where the board is
treated like a tourus introduces a
fascinating twist to the classic game by
the way GPT is clearly trained to butter
you up it's kind of hilarious it's
always telling you how fascinating and
important your questions are anyway to
resume in a toroidal chess board the
edges of the board are effectively
connected meaning the pieces can move
from one Edge to the other as if the
board is looping around this
dramatically changes the strategy and
tactics of the game regarding the
question of whether white or black would
generally win in this version and then
then it just fill Busters again it goes
through all of these statements it says
first move advantage in traditional
chess white is generally considered to
have a slight Advantage due to the first
move this principle might still hold in
toroidal chess but the extent of the
advantage could be different due to the
alra Dynamics of Peace movement and
board geometry and then it goes altered
strategies and tactics the toal nature
would significantly change the middle
game and endgame strategies
unpredictability and complexity the toal
board adds a level of complexity blah
blah blah blah okay right lack of
empirical data it complains that it
doesn't know anything about this
hypothetical variation of Chess and it
concludes with while might might sorry
while white might still retain some
level of first move advantage in
toroidal chess the unique Dynamics
introduced by the board's topology could
significantly alter how this Advantage
plays out the outcome would likely
depend more on players adapt
adaptability and innovation in strategy
under the new
rules there you go complete utter
nonsense everything it said but of
course it's not random nonsense it's
highly sophisticated nonsense all of
these words all of these sentences sound
kind of like things that would be
perfectly reasonable to say under very
very similar circumstances but what is
not going on is that GPT is not
envisioning a chessboard and seeing how
it would change by this new toroidal
chessboard kind of thing and is not
analyzing or reasoning about it because
llms don't do that they don't model the
world okay that was a lot of examples I
hope you could um pass through them none
of this is definitive by the way this is
why I'm doing a solo podcast not writing
an academic paper about it um I thought
about writing an academic paper about it
actually but I think that there are
people who are more more um more
credential to do that no more more
knowledgeable about the background you
know I I do think that even though I
should be talking about it and should
have opinions about this stuff I don't
quite have the background knowledge of
previous work and data uh that has been
already collected etc etc to actually
take time out and contribute to the
academic literature on it but if anyone
wants to you know write about this
either inspired by this podcast or um so
an actual expert in AI wants to
collaborate on it just let me know I
hope the point comes through more
importantly which is that it's hard but
not that hard to ask large language
models questions that it doesn't answers
doesn't get the correct answers to
specifically because it is not modeling
the world it's doing something else but
it is not modeling the world in the way
that human beings do so Point number two
and these will be these will be quick
points I think don't worry it's not
going to be a 4-Hour podcast Don't Panic
Point number two is that large language
models don't have feelings and I'm
meaning feelings in the sense of Antonio
deasio remember when we talked to
Antonio about feelings and Neuroscience
and and homeostasis and and human beings
um the closely related claim would be
llms don't have motivations or goals or
Tey so this is my way of thinking about
the fact that human beings and other
biological organisms have a lot going on
other than simply their cognitive
capacities Okay so we've talked with
various people uh Lisa a ad from aiz a
from like very early podcast Andy Clark
more recently about embodied cognition
about the fact that our our own thinking
doesn't simply happen in our brain it
happens in our body as well to me as a
physicist philosopher and if anyone has
read the big picture you know what I'm
talking about here it's crucially
important that human beings are out of
equilibrium that human beings live in an
entropy gradient that we are in fact
quasi homeostatic systems embedded in an
entropy gradient so human beings and
other organisms developed over the
course of biological time okay so again
and I'll state it again at the very end
there's no obstacle and principle to
precisely duplicating every feature of a
human being in an artificial context but
we haven't okay so just because it's
possible and principle doesn't mean
we've already done it and one of the
crucially important features of human
beings that we haven't even tried very
hard to duplicate in AIS or large
language models is that the particular
thoughts in our minds have Arisen
because of this biological evolution
this biological evolution that is
training us as quasi homeostatic systems
where homeostatic means maintaining our
internal equilibrium okay so if we get a
little too cold we try to warm ourselves
up if we get hungry we try to eat etc
etc we have various urges various
feelings as deasio would say that let us
know we should fix something about our
internal States and this status as qu
quasi homeostatic static system
uh develops over biological time because
we have descendants and they're a little
bit different than us and different ones
will have different survival strategies
and you know the whole darwinian natural
selection story so it is absolutely
Central to who we are that part of our
biology has the purpose of keeping us
alive of giving us motivation to stay
alive of giving us signals that things
should be a certain way and they're not
so they need to be fixed whether it's
something very obvious like hunger or
pain or even things like you know
boredom or anxiety okay all these
different kinds of feelings that are
telling us that something isn't quite
right and we should do something about
them nothing like this exists for large
language models because again they're
not trying to right that's not what
they're meant to do large language
models don't get bored they they don't
get hungry they don't get impatient they
don't have goals and why does this
matter well because there's an enormous
amount of talk about values and things
like that that don't really apply to
large language models even though we
apply them I think that this is why in
order to that the discourse about Ai and
its dangers and its future needs to
involve
people who are experts in computer
science and AI but also needs to involve
people who are experts in philosophy and
biology and Neuroscience and sociology
and many other fields and not only do
they have to involve these different
kinds of people but they need to talk to
each other and listen you know it's it's
one thing and I know this as someone who
does interdisciplinary work it's one
thing to get people in a room it's a
very different thing to actually get
them to listen to to each other and that
is is not just a demand on The Listener
it's a demand on the talker as well that
they need to be able to talk to other
people in ways that are understandable
okay these are all skills that that are
sadly not very valued by the current
academic structure that we have right
now
so I think that it is that among people
who study AI the fact that llms are
mimicking human speech but without the
motivations and the go s and the
internal regulatory apparatuses that
come along with being a biological
organism is just completely
underappreciated okay so again they
could you can imagine evolving AIS you
can imagine evolving llms you could
imagine the different weights of the
neurons uh randomly generated and rather
than just optimizing to some function
that is basically being judged by human
beings you could have them compete
against each other you could put them in
a world where there is sensory apparatus
right you could put the AIS in robots
with bodies and you could have them die
if they don't succeed and you could have
them pass on their linear you could do
all of that stuff but you're not that's
not what is actually going on so to me
when you think about the behavior of AIS
this fact that they don't have feelings
and motivations could not possibly be
more important right uh I I'm sure I've
said this before in the podcast I say it
all the time when I fire up chat
GPT on my web browser and I don't ask it
a question it does not get annoyed with
me if I went to my class to teach and
just sat there in Silence the students
would get kind of annoyed or worried or
something right time flows entropy
increases people change inside people
are are not static you know I could just
turn off my computer turn it on again a
day later and pick up my conversation
with GPT where we left off and it would
not know it would not care that matters
it matters to how you think about this
thing you have built if you want to say
that we are approaching AGI artificial
general intelligence then you have
to take into account the fact that real
intelligence serves a purpose
serves the purpose of homeostatically
regulating us as biological organisms
again maybe that is not your goal maybe
you don't want to do that maybe that's
fine maybe you can better serve the
purposes of your llm by not giving it
goals and motivations by not letting it
get annoyed and frustrated and things
like that but annoyance and frustration
aren't just sub routines I guess that's
the right way of putting it you can't
just program the llm to speak in a
slightly tone of voice or to you know
pop up after a certain time period
elapses if no one has asked it a
question that's not what I mean that's
just fake motivation annoyance etc for
real human beings these feelings that we
have that tell us to adjust our internal
parameters to something that is more
appropriate are crucial to who we are
they are not little sub routines that
are running in the background that may
or may not be called at any one time
okay
so until you do that until you built in
those crucial features of how biological
organisms work you cannot even imagine
that what you have is truly a general
kind of
intelligence okay which moves me right
on to the third thing I wanted to say
which is that the words that we use to
describe these AIS words like
intelligence and values are misleading
and this is where the philosoph opy
comes in with a Vengeance because this
is something that philosophers and even
scientists to a lesser extent are pretty
familiar with where you have words that
have been used in natural language for
hundreds or thousands of years right not
the exact words probably for thousands
of years but they develop over time in
some kind of smooth Evolution kind of
way and we know what we mean like we
like philosophers will tell you that we
human beings on the street are not very
good at having precise definitions of
words but we know what we mean right we
see you know we talk to different people
if you say oh this person seems more
intelligent than that person we have a
rough idea of what is going on even if
you cannot precisely Define what the
word intelligence means okay and the
point is that's fine in that context and
this is where both scientists and
philosophers should know very well we
move outside of the familiar context all
the time phys IST use words like energy
or Dimension or whatever in in ways in
senses that are very different from what
ordinary human beings imagine you you I
cannot overemphasize the number of times
I've had to explain to people the two
particles being entangled with each
other doesn't mean like there's a string
connecting them it doesn't mean like if
I move one the other one Jiggles in
response because the word entanglement
kind of gives you that impression right
and entanglement is a very useful
English word that has been chosen to
mean something very specific in the
context of quantum mechanics and we have
to remember those definitions are a
little bit different here what's going
on is kind of related to that but but
not quite the same where we're importing
words like intelligence and values and
pretending that they mean the same thing
when they really don't so large language
models again they're meant to mimic
humans right that's their success
Criterion that they sound s human so it
is not surprising that they sound like
they are intelligent it is not
surprising that they sound like they
have values right but that doesn't mean
that they do it would be very weird if
the large language models didn't sound
intelligent or like they had values I
think you know I don't know whether this
is true or not so maybe saying even I
think is too strong but there is this
Trope in science fiction Star Trek most
notably where you have some kind of
humanlike creature that doesn't have
emotions right whether it was Spock in
the original series or data in the Next
Generation or whatever and there's a
kind of stereotypical way that appears
to us right you know they don't know
when to laugh they you know they don't
ever smile they're kind of uh affectless
Etc so we kind of I don't know which
came first chicken or kind of thing but
many of us have the idea that if you
don't have emotions values intelligence
that's how you will appear as some kind
of not very emotional seeming taciturn
robotic kind of thing but of course here
you've trained the large language models
to seem as human as possible this is why
Spock and data are so annoying to
scientists I mean we love them of course
because it's a great TV show Etc but
realistically it would not have been
hard
to give data for example all the
abilities that he had as an Android and
also teach him how to laugh at jokes
right that is the least of the difficult
thing so the fact that when you talk to
an llm it can sound intelligent and and
seem to have values is zero evidence
that it actually does in the sense that
we use those words for human beings
clearly llms are able to answer
correctly with some probability uh very
difficult questions many questions that
human beings would not be very good at
you know if I asked a typical human
being on the street to come up with a
possible syllabus for my course in
philosophical naturalism they would do
much worse than GPT did okay so sure it
sounds intelligent to me but that's the
point sounding intelligent doesn't mean
that it's the same kind of intelligence
likewise with values values are even
more of a super important test case if
you hang around AI circles they will all
they will very frequently talk about the
value alignment problem what they mean
by that is making sure that these AIS
which they believe many of them believe
are going to be extremely powerful that
they better have values that align with
the values of human beings uh you've all
heard the classic paperclip maximizer
example where you you know some AI that
has access to a factory and robots is
told to make as many paper clips as it
can and it just takes over the world and
it you know converts everything to
making paper clips even though that's
not really what the human beings meant
uh some version of asimov's Laws of
Robotics might have been helpful here
but my point is not that this isn't a
worry maybe it is maybe it isn't but
that telling an AI that it's supposed to
make a lot of paper clips is not giving
it a value that's not what values mean
values are not instructions you can't
help but follow okay values come along
with this idea of human beings being
biological organisms that evolved over
billions of years in this
non-equilibrium environment we evolved
to survive and pass on our genomes to
our subsequent
Generations um if you're familiar with
the discourse on moral constructivism
all this should be very familiar moral
constructivism is the idea that morals
are not objectively out there in the
world nor are they just completely uh
made up or arbitrary they are
constructed by human beings for certain
definable reasons because human beings
are biological creatures every one of
which has some motivations right has
some feelings has some preferences for
how things should be
and moral philosophy as far as the
constructivist is concerned is the
process by which we systematize and make
rational our underlying moral intuitions
and
inclinations llms have no underlying
moral intuitions and inclinations and
giving them instructions is not the same
thing again this is where the careful
philosophical thinking comes to play you
can use the word value to to mean the
same thing you can say well I I'm using
the word value I don't really mean
values in the same way for llms as for
human beings but you're kind of gliding
between the connotations of these
different words in order to have values
in other words and I'm not trying to
give you the final answer I'm not trying
to say here is how we should think about
intelligence or values or whatever I'm
just trying to point out the very
obvious thing which is that whatever
llms have it is not the same thing that
we have when we talk about intelligence
or values or morals or goals or anything
like that and hilariously I did test by
by asking GPT
this I said you know uh GPT do you have
values and it instantly said oh no no no
I don't have any values I'm not a human
being we don't think like that right I'm
sure it's been trained to say that in in
various ways you know the thing about
the large language models is that they
both read in all all the text they can
possibly get but then that's not the end
of the story right they are trained to
not say certain things because a lot of
that stuff they're reading is like super
racist and sexist and stuff like that so
there is a layer on top um it's pretty
clear to me that the GPD has been told
to not say that it is conscious to say
that is not conscious I don't know if it
was explicitly told to say that it
doesn't have values but it certainly
does say that so this is a case where I
would agree with GPT that whatever it is
it's not the same kind of thing that a
human being is the point is that you
again you have just from growing up as a
human being a picture of what it means
to be intelligent you you you see that
you know if there's something out there
if there's a person that can answer
questions and they can carry on a
conversation and they can can propose
ideas you hadn't thought of you say
that's intelligent there it is and then
you talk with the llms and they do all
those things therefore it is the perfect
ly natural thing for you or I to
attribute the rest of the connotations
of being intelligent also to these
llms but you shouldn't it's not valid in
this case they're not thinking in the
same way they're not valuing in the same
way that's not to say that the actual
work being done under the rubric of
value alignment is not important if what
you mean by value alignment is making
sure AIS don't harm human beings that's
fine
but I think that thinking of it
portraying it as values is making a
mistake at Step Zero right that's if
what you're actually trying to do is to
just do AI safety to make sure that AI
is not going to do things that we didn't
want it to do then say that don't call
it value alignment because that's not an
an accurate description and it comes
along with implications that you really
don't want it to okay okay the final
thing that I wanted to say was there is
something remarkable going on here
remember I said it would be remarkable
if AIS if the large language models
anyway had actually spontaneously and
without being told to developed models
of the world because models of the world
were the best ways to answer the
questions that they were optimized to
answer and they probably wouldn't do
that it's also remarkable that they do
as well as they do I think that's
perfectly fair to say and is completely
compatible with the other thing I said
large language models can seem very
smart and in fact they can seem
empathetic they can seem like they're
sympathizing with you empathizing with
you that they you know understand your
problems there's all these famous cases
of people working at tech companies who
you know fall in love with their large
language models literally in love like
romantic love not like they really are
impressed by it or value it that they
think that they have a relationship with
it
that's a fascinating Discovery because
precisely because they don't think in
the same way right so the discovery
seems to me to not be that by training
these gigantic computer programs to give
human sounding
responses they have developed a way of
thinking that is similar to how human
think humans think that is not the
discovery the discovery is by training
large language models to give aners that
are similar to what humans would give
they figured out a way to do that
without thinking the way that human
beings do that's why I say it there's a
discovery here there's something to
really be remarked on which is how
surprisingly easy it is to mimic
humanness to mimic sounding human
without actually being human if you
would ask me 10 years ago or whatever if
you ask many people I think that many
people who
were skeptical about AI I wasn't I was
not super skeptical myself but I knew
that AI had been worked on for decades
and the progress was slower than people
had hoped uh so I knew about that level
of skepticism that was out there in the
community I didn't have strong opinions
myself either way but I think that part
of that skepticism was justified by
saying something like there's something
going on in human brains that we don't
know what it is and it's not spooky or
mystical but it's complicated the brain
is a complicated place and we don't know
how to reproduce those mechanisms those
procedures that are going on in human
brains therefore human sounding AI is a
long way off and the huge finding the
absolutely amazing thing is that it was
not nearly that far off even though we
don't mimic the way human beings think
so what that seems to to be to imply as
far as I can tell is that you know
there's only there's only two
possibilities here that I can think of
and again not an expert happy to hear
otherwise one possibility is that human
beings despite the complexity of our
brains are ultimately at the end of the
day pretty simple information processing
machines you know and and thought of as
input output devices thought of as you
know if some sensory input comes into
this black box and it does the following
things maybe we're just not that
complicated maybe we're computationally
pretty simple right computational
complexity theorists think about these
questions uh what is the relationship
between inputs and outputs is it very
complicated is it very simple and so
forth maybe we human beings are just
simpler than we think maybe kind of a
short lookup table is enough to describe
most human interactions at the end of
the day short is still pretty long but
not as long as we might like um the
other possibility is that we are
actually pretty complex pretty
unpredictable um
but that that complexity is mostly held
in reserve right that for the most part
when we talk to each other um when we
even when we write and when we speak and
so forth mostly we're running on
autopilot or at least we're just only
engaging relatively simple parts of our
cognitive capacities and only in certain
special circumstances whatever they are
do we really take full advantage of our
inner complexity
I could see it going either way and so
that would be that latter hypothesis
would be compatible with the idea that
it's hard to ask an llm a question that
it gets wrong because of its inability
to model the world but it's not
impossible and I think that that's what
it turns out to be correct so maybe
that's it you know like maybe human
beings for the most part at the 99%
level are pretty simple in their inputs
and outputs and and how they react to
the world and
also maybe that makes sense
um the other thing about the fact that
we're biological organisms rather than
uh computers is that we are the product
of many many generations of compromises
and constraints and resource demands
right it's always been a question for uh
historians anthropologists
Etc why human beings got so smart you
know we talked a little bit with uh
Peter Godfrey Smith about this and and
certainly we've talked to people like
Michael tomasello or France Dall about
the development of human intelligence
and it costs resources it costs food to
power our brains you know our brains are
thermodynamically pretty efficient in
terms of like number of computations we
don't generate a lot of heat your head
generates less heat than your laptop
that's a physically noticeable fact the
computers that we build are not very
thermodynamically efficient that's a um
Frontier that people are moving moving
forward on trying to make computers
generate less heat but our brains are
pretty good at it we don't need that
much energy input to do the computations
we do um but we're not unbounded right
you know we our brains make us
vulnerable hit on the head pretty
damaging to a human being um food is
required etc etc you know when we're
born we're pretty helpless there's a
whole bunch of things that come into the
reality of being a biological organism
that help explain why and how we think
in the way that we do so maybe it's not
surprising that for the most part we
human beings are pretty simple and mimic
right um uh fool there can be an
illusion of thought going on in
relatively simple ways and maybe you
don't even notice the difference until
you really probe the edges of when we
human beings are put our brains putting
our brains to work in their in the
biggest part of their capacities so
again I'm going to just reemphasize here
I am not trying to say that AI is not
ever going to be generally intelligent
that is absolutely possible and I'm
certainly not saying that it's not super
smart seeming I'm saying the opposite of
that I hope that's clear that's the
point is that the llms do seem super
smart and for many purposes that's
enough right if you want to generate a
syllabus if you want to generate a
recipe look if you say I have these
ingredient in my kitchen what is a good
recipe you know for a dinner that I can
make from these llms are amazing at that
that's great and you know they might
give you some bad advice so you should
think it through but they can see those
kinds of things because they have access
to every cookbook ever written and so
forth it's just a different kind of
thinking than happens when human beings
are really thinking things through which
by the way not completely coincidentally
is how human beings think at the highest
level of scientific research I would not
be surprised if large language models
became absolutely ubiquitous did a lot
of you know writing of um sports game
summaries right summarize this game I
think I suspect that that happens a lot
already and you don't know it I suspect
a lot of the writeups of um football
games and basketball games on espn.com
Etc are written by large language models
um but and maybe that's fun
but they never or not never but maybe
they do not in at any reasonable time
scale become good at the kinds of
insights that are needed to do
cuttingedge scientific research um or
maybe they do I don't know but that
given everything that we've said so far
that would not surprise me and the same
exact thing can be said about art um and
and literature and poetry and things
like that maybe the llms will be able to
do really good good art and literature
and poetry because they've read and seen
every bit of art and literature and
poetry ever but they won't be able to be
quite new in the same way that human
beings are and again again again again
as I keep saying that's not to say that
some different approach or some hybrid
approach to AI couldn't be there's
nothing completely unique and special
about human beings but specifically the
approach of just dumping in everything
that's ever been done and looking for
patterns and trying to reproduce
reasonable sentences has some built-in
limitations okay so the lesson here the
the idea that I'm trying to get at at
the end of this podcast is I think it's
important to talk about the capabilities
of LMS and other modern AIS even if
those capabilities do not rise to the
status of being artificial general
intelligence you know I I've not talked
about existential risks I said I would
not but I'll just say once again
frequent listeners know my take on this
but I'll say once again what that take
is I don't think it's very useful to
think to worry too much about the
existential risks of artificial
intelligence by existential risks I mean
literally the kinds of risks that could
lead to the extinction of the human race
right X risks as they are called because
everyone loves a good fun little bit of
labeling marketing um now I know the
argument the argument is there there's
two parts to the argument one is even if
the chances of an existential risk are
very very tiny come on it matters a lot
if you literally are worried about
destroying the whole human race even a
small chance should be taken very very
seriously I do get that I do appreciate
that that is part of it but the other
part is just kind of nonsense because
the other part is something like and I'm
not making this up this is what people
say look basically you're building an
intelligent creature that will soon be
much more intelligent than us Godlike
intelligence and therefore we are not
going to be able to outsmart this
creature and therefore it will be able
to do whatever it wants to do if we try
to stop it from doing it it will be
smarter than us and therefore it will
not be able to be controlled by we poor
puny hum because we are not as smart as
it okay that's the other part of the
argument that so that that second part
is what leads to there is at least a
tiny chance of existential risk and then
the first part says if there's even just
a tiny chance it's worth worrying about
and it's the there is even a tiny chance
argument that seems completely
unconvincing to me of course there's
always a tiny chance but also guess what
there's a tiny chance that AI will save
us from existential threats right that
maybe there's other other existential
threats whether it's biowarfare or
nuclear war or climate change or
whatever that are much more likely than
the AI existential risks and maybe the
best chance we have of saving ourselves
is to get help from AI okay so just the
fact that you can possibly conjure an
existential threat scenario doesn't mean
that it is a net bad for the world but
my real argument is with this whole
Godlike intelligence thing because I
hope I giving you the impression uh I
hope I've successfully conveyed the
reasons why I think that thinking about
llms in terms of intelligence and values
and goals is just
wrongheaded that's not to say they don't
have enormous capacities I think they're
going to be everywhere I think there's
you know very very direct shortterm
worries about AI from misinformation
from Faking from things that seem
reasonable but aren't there's all sorts
of stories already about AI being used
to judge whether people are sick or not
whether people deserve parole or not
whether people deserve to be hired or
not or get health insurance or not and
they're usually pretty good but they
make mistakes that kind of stuff I think
is super important to worry about
because it's right here right now it's
not a scenario that we specula specul
relatively have to make up and maybe
more importantly depending on where
you're coming
from I think that we should work hard to
be careful and safe and regulate those
kinds of worries and if we do that we
will handle the existential risks in
other words I think that if we actually
focus on the real world short-term very
very obvious risks that are big and
looming but fall short of wiping out the
human race we will make it much more
likely that there won't be any
existential risks to the human race
because we will get much better at
regulating and controlling and keeping
AI safe all of which in my mind will be
helped by accurately thinking about what
AI is not by borrowing words that we use
to describe human beings and kind of
thoughtlessly porting them over to the
large language model context
I don't know anything about open ai's
qstar
program everything that I've said here
might turn out to be entirely obsolete a
couple weeks after I posted or whatever
but as of right now when I'm recording
this podcast I think it is hilariously
unlikely that whatever qar or any of the
competitor programs are they are
anything that we would recognize as
artificial general intelligence in the
human way of being um maybe that that
will come again I see no obstacles and
principle to that happening but I don't
think it's happening anytime soon I
think that the next generation of young
people thinking hard about these things
will probably have a lot to say about
that which is what I always like to do
here on mindscape to encourage that next
Generation because I think that we're
not done yet we've not yet figured it
out we're not talking about these
questions in anything like the right way
I think the real breakthroughs are yet
to come let's make sure that we think
about them carefully and make progress
responsibly
[Music]
w